[Music]
remember if you enjoy what we do at the
spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
the national health service turned 74
this week in recent years the health
service has received billions upon
billions of extra funding from the
taxpayer but public satisfaction with
the health service is at its lowest in
20 years what's going on i'm joined now
by our assistant editor isabel hardman
isabel thanks for joining spectator tv
so this week marks the 74th birthday of
the national health service but
celebrations seem somewhat muted this
year can you give us a sense of what's
going on in the nhs at the moment
well i think things are pretty pretty
miserable in the nhs at the moment which
is why you didn't see that much
celebrating in fact i spent quite a lot
of
tuesday talking to nhs figures and
it was only sort of halfway through the
the calls and the meetings that we
suddenly remembered oh yes it's the
birthday and so that that's sort of the
mentally where they are that there's the
backlog um which uh
if you talk to people working within the
health service they'll say that they're
doing their very best to tackle as
quickly as they can and they thought
they were doing okay but the latest wave
of covid
is again really affecting them
um and is slowing progress because of
staff absences and so on um
there's also uh these uh efficiency
savings that the nhs is being expected
to make it's supposed to double its
efficiency rate to 2.2 which is a huge
ask of the health service
uh in in any circumstances but with
inflation um
there's a lot of worries uh that that's
going to be a real squeeze in terms of
how much everything costs and that's
something that amanda pritchard who is
the chief executive of nhs england has
already been laying down markers um she
gave a speech to the nhs confederation
last week where she said that you know
budgets can only stretch so far and you
can see the nhs saying
either it can't meet those targets which
pritchard at the moment is saying it can
um
or
just trying to to push back against any
suggestion for from ministers
and obviously currently i believe steve
barkley is still the health secretary
he's very into efficiencies um that they
might try to squeeze things further
well i was going to say it's difficult
to talk about what the government thinks
when it comes to the nhs seeing as the
government is currently collapsing all
around us
but ministers previous to this current
upset in westminster and whoever forms
the next government going forward do you
think they're waking up to the realities
facing the nhs
uh
yes and no um
so i i think um
that the treasury
is not um and the reason i say that is
that um it had blocked uh very
forcefully
any attempts to do proper workforce
planning and which would
in the long term
help the nhs to be more efficient
because it is hugely inefficient if you
have massive gaps on your rotors and if
you have
so many vacancies within the health
service if you
cannot actually
perform
the operations that you need to because
you just don't have the nurses you don't
have the doctors um and so on and uh
and this is this is a sort of ongoing
problem um in terms of the uh the other
aspect of reality which is i think a
point that you make um
a fair bit cake which is about the
actual sustainability of the nhs as it
is i mean politically that is really
really difficult and recently there was
a paper that tony blair published and
that argued uh that the current model uh
is not sustainable and i have to say
having uh just finished writing a
history of the nhs for its 75th birthday
um
i've heard that phrase so many times i
think it starts to appear from the sort
of late 1960s onwards that the beven and
beveridge model uh no longer works in
today's society um the problem is is
that the solutions to that um there are
the um sort of outlier solutions
of scrapping it and going for something
completely different insurance-based
model um which is not only in america
but in other countries in europe and
does work uh well for uh people in in
europe so we you know it's always worth
pointing out that it's not uh the uk or
america and those are the only two
models in the whole world we do have a
slightly bigger world than that um
or changing um some of the structures
within the health service and this is
the the point that tony blair has been
making that he wants to
basically collapse the central control
over the health service and give
integrated care boards which are
responsible for the commissioning and
provision of nhs services
control over pretty much everything and
that's just not going to work with the
dna of the nhs which you know was set up
um to be a highly centralized highly
controlled
system that was one of bevan's
objectives in nationalising the
hospitals
it was one of the things that he said
himself that he would be the chief
receiver of complaints and ever since
then whether health secretaries have
legally been responsible for this or
legally distanced from that they have
always ended up talking about the
bedpans that have been dropped in
hospitals hundreds of miles away they
have always ended up forcing out chief
executives who aren't performing whether
or not that's their legal duty i mean
there's a quote by alan johnson for
instance um about mid-staffs where uh he
had civil servants buzzing around him
saying oh you can't do this you can't do
that and he just turned around and said
piss off i'm dealing with this um and
that's that you know that's ultimately
what it comes down to is the public
expect ministers to answer questions on
everything when it comes to the health
service and i don't quite see how that's
going to change
the the spectator data hub is keeping
track of public satisfaction with the
nhs and at the moment there are actually
more people who say they're quite or
very dissatisfied with its performance
compared to those who are satisfied but
what should we read into those quite
headline statistics
yeah so there's there's lots of
interesting dynamics there one is the
political dynamic of who do the public
blame and they tend to blame the
politicians who they think are
um
are underfunding not supporting the
health service
properly there's also the
thing that
particularly
the later labour years the politicians
then really picked up which was the but
we're lucky dynamics so
you get people saying oh the nhs is in a
terrible state but we're lucky with our
local hospital and sort of still
uh bought into it at a local level which
can be um
hugely frustrating and disruptive
for anyone trying to embark on sensible
reforms because actually sometimes
people aren't lucky with their local
hospital and it would make more sense to
close you know the accident in emergency
into centralized services but
you never get a hospital closure that
the local politician or indeed that the
local
sort of vocal population are are going
to support and say you end up with
services remaining
even when it's not particularly
economical to do so
isabel in your upcoming book you
demonstrate how the nhs has been a
battleground for some of the fiercest
political contests of our time
as we look forward to an election
possibly in 2024 maybe sooner or indeed
a leadership election just within the
conservative party how is the nhs going
to figure
i think it will figure very highly uh
because you are already getting
headlines about the number of people who
are dying while on nhs waiting lists
you're seeing this really interesting
phenomenon of people crowdfunding for
private medical treatment so
um private medical insurance has gone up
and down depending on who's in
government the state of the nhs but
actually people who are paying upfront
rather than taking out insurance
for an operation that they need but have
been told they have a year to wait for
and in that time they worry that they're
going to get sicker or that their
quality of life is going to plummet they
just can't wait in pain for that long so
they're going on to these gofundme sites
and so on to try to cover their their
private health care um themselves and
so
when i talk to people in the health
service and when i talk to switched on
politicians about this they see the nhs
as being in
it's probably its greatest existential
crisis since its foundation even greater
than um at the the turn of the century
in 2000 when uh people like alan milburn
tony blair were genuinely worried the
public support for the nhs was going to
was just going to disappear public
consent was was going to disappoint
you'd get middle classes um opting out
and the consent of the middle classes
was really important at the time of the
foundation of the health service um
and so we're back in that place again
now uh you're gonna have a lot of people
getting very upset um in you know
hustings uh in election question times
and so on about their mother who has
been you know left to die by four
cancelled operations which was one of
the things the mavis skeet case that
that prompted a big revolution in health
service back in 2000
and that said
it isn't necessarily the case that the
nhs uh
always wins elections four parties and
that's the risk for labour is that they
could end up talking about the nhs uh
while not actually reassuring the public
or on anything else if you look at the
1992 election where the nhs um was a key
part of labour's campaign didn't win
them that election so uh so in terms of
a political battleground um
uh for actually winning an election i
think there's a there's a caveat there
but it will feature really heavily in
the in the campaign one last question
for you isabel on the politics of this
uh over the past five or six years when
it comes to election time and there have
been quite a few what politicians
promise isn't reform it's more money
and this has really increased uh the the
funding of the nhs uh to the point where
it is now well above the oecd
average it's increasingly difficult to
say that the nhs is underfunded do you
think politicians are going to have to
start offering something else or do you
think the public may still buy into this
idea that if we just give it a bit more
money and i'm thinking of the new
national insurance levy of course that
workers are paying now for the nhs
ketchup and the rest of it you know do
people still think that the answer is
more money or are they expecting to hear
something different from their
politicians
i think the way in which the public
reacts to attempts to reform social care
is quite instructive in this in that um
they
expect things to continue to be free
even though social care isn't free for
them at the moment and um
they get very upset at the idea that
they might have to um
expect a sort of lower level of service
even though the level of service and
social care is appalling as well so
um i
do not think that being honest with the
public about the health service uh tends
to benefit politicians and
you know we saw that in the 2017 snap
election with social care where theresa
may basically tried to uh yeah i
interviewed her about this for the book
and uh she said that the basic problem
was that they tried to be honest with
the electorate and um that
it was not something the electorate
appreciated and they don't like actually
being told about the the state of um the
state of things and how much
it is either going to cost or how much a
health service is going to have to
change and
for good or bad and you know you've
written about this kate about the the
problem with the sort of british
emotional attachment to the nhs
um brits don't want to see a change to
the model and um
they don't want to see their local
hospital killed even when as many
politicians have said to me that hos
local hospital is literally killing
people they will still present petitions
saying don't close this hospital um
and so uh you know good luck to anyone
who wants to be honest um about the uh
about the
alternative options but i suspect that
uh that they won't get thanked for it
but just
another example from history um kate
used to work for the iea institute of
economic affairs and they got very upset
uh
with enoch powell for saying that there
was no point in um in arguing against
the national health service as it was
because it was something that the public
wanted they wrote to him saying see how
you have comforted our enemy i think you
know if enoch powell had sort of
cottoned on to that then i suspect that
a lot of conservative politicians today
are probably going to draw back and
think now
[Music]
you